[Music]
type in so tight don't even know what
I'm talking about I'm ripe Westbrook to
my left take your soul but leave your
breath hey that was I don't even want to
freestyle I'm just I was typing really
hard like sometimes when I'm typing
enums like yo you must be mad at some
you had a message that you were trying
to get across whatever that was it was
important I know I when you type into
agent she gives money at all and this is
what I mean say it like this tell you
what your chests right Brian Westbrook
we're in the Washington Nationals cap
represent did you celebrate it's really
funny so Warren lives in DC yes we're up
in DC I didn't know you lived in a lot
of Nationals talking yeah I know you
lived in DC yeah that's pretty cool
actually I guess so
when I see the key lies in the Pentagon
it makes me laugh
the mustache it's just every time I see
I'm like I'm buddy laugh so for
Halloween I was going to get a mustache
and wear a sweater with a blazer you
should have but his is it it's so
perfect this is how Warren is I'm gonna
I may have said this already in the pot
Warren came down one Wednesday night
usually he comes down Thursday and then
he leaves right away so one one's think
he knows let's do dinner there's a pizza
place on Sixth Avenue that's like a
nicer place and they sat us outside huh
and Warren goes Adam can we please sit
inside and I go yeah sure so I got up
and went inside and I go what's wrong
and he goes there's a higher probability
of me getting sick if we sit outside and
I was like wow and he was he was serious
dead-ass and I'm the [ __ ] the
table with tequila bein like Warren
you're [ __ ] like a [ __ ] what I
work so like I there's part of me that
wants like fake sneeze all over him just
to see so he's a germaphobe I just think
he's like I perform it I do not want to
imitate him optimal possess optimal
performance and wipe and I think it's
also with his kids like he knows and
kids can make him sick yeah
germaphobe that's what that thanked all
of that yeah I think he if he gets dust
in his hardware he could break he's like
you know those insurance agents they're
always looking at the probabilities yeah
yeah there's a 25% chance this is gonna
happen yeah and I got to prevent that
he's like that with football I like that
yeah I kind of like that that was the
type of guys you want to hang out with
because they're constantly funny I think
about him during Sunday's all the time
because one he said over in Oakland
Detroit had there were two he said
Russell Wilson's can have a huge game
because they're gonna need to get rid of
the running game that happened we did
like 20 minutes on the Friday pot about
how the Ravens have the advantage over
everything on the Patriots but both of
us kind of chickened out because it's
Bill Belichick but we were right
Warren is it's [ __ ] crazy it really
is well he knows the numbers but he also
understands the game just enough that
you when you talk to people do you know
if the editor of the scant understand
the game right away
can you tell you got a good feeling I
mean when you start talking the game you
got a good feeling they understand it or
they're just like listen this is what
the book says and this is the way I'm
playing it yes and there's a lot of guys
that understand the numbers but the
numbers can lie oh they had 41 carries
they're a running team well no how about
they were up by 21 and they ran 20 run
plays in the second half the numbers
gonna lie is my point you know what I
this is not a lie the one thing I was
upset about last week's show when I was
in London was we did not get to do
dolphin tank yes so we're very sorry yes
let's enter the dolphin tank we're not
gonna wait any longer
it was a great week nine there were
monster games and I think this first
dolphin tank it is funny we're doing
dolphin tanking the Dolphins won though
you believe that they want that's how
bad the Jets have been since oh my god
they stink when you lose everything but
that's why Ryan Fitzpatrick is the
greatest tanking quarterback of all time
okay dolphin tank welcome back to dumpin
Tech which is temporarily being
rebranded as Bengals tank for as long as
the development around the winning
streak Ryan Fitzpatrick just wins
football games
first into the tank we've got a special
guest voice-over artist
hi I'm Connor Rogers from stick to
football left goes of the controversial
opinion that one player will end up
winning the MVP this year and that this
player may or may not end up being a
quarterback the quarterback that he
believes is this year's frontrunner has
a strong arm at twice as many strong
legs he's looking for an investment of 1
million quarter bucks in exchange for a
68% completion percentage or higher
quarter bucks
shout out to Connor Rodgers from stick
to football
viki's what's good twice as many strong
legs this quarterback is mobile and he
can throw this quarterback was probably
doubted early on but has come around to
be quite successful and this quarterback
put on an absolute show on Sunday to
carry his team to victory and closer to
the playoffs will you invest a million
quarter bucks into this star quarterback
is that to be the MVP is that all the
information I get yeah that his team won
he did they did it was unbelievable he
made plays in the clutch that without
him they would not have won and I
believe he is the existence first win no
they won a lot of games I think that
this guy could be the MVP this is who I
think is gonna win the MVP ok so you
think he could be an MVP they just want
they just want to gain yeah
incredible ok they're like their top 5
record in the NFL yeah and yeah I'll
take that
ok yeah right now why wouldn't you okay
so who do you think it is I have no clue
I think I think obviously you think
Lamar first thing I think Russell Wilson
yeah I think obviously Aaron didn't have
a very good game yeah Phillip Rivers
went off now that's how fill of room he
didn't really go up but he played well
um there's one other one in London place
for the Texans tannenhill nope so think
you said Titans goodness can I be honest
oh you just bought russell wilson
deshaun Watson and Lamar jacks all
winners because I don't know this was a
shark tank where I don't have my opinion
picked out yet like I know that those
are the three guys that are the face
Hertz right now for the MVP yeah and I
can't choose and so what you've bought
is the dilemma of the MVP debate you
spent a million quarter bucks to help me
figure this out right now let's figure
it out Lamar Russell Wilson or deshaun
Watson let us first give them all praise
yes because they are all deserving
deshaun Watson I want to say this right
off the bat I apologize I have never
spoke poorly about you but I have spoke
poorly about your coach Bill O'Brien and
I have spoke very poorly about your team
the Houston Texans I thought of all the
teams heading into the season the three
that I were most sure that would regress
were the Chicago Bears the Los Angeles
chargers and yes you the Houston Texans
I did not realize that you were going to
go from star in this league to super
star in this league I did not realize
you were gonna be able to overcome the
loss of Jadeveon Clowney and the loss of
JJ Watt I did not realize you're gonna
be able to overcome your coaches bad
play calling I did not realize you to be
able to overcome a level the loss of
Lamar Miller or the fact that I find
your defense to be very average I didn't
realize I didn't realize you were gonna
be that [ __ ] good so that's what I
want to say about deshaun Watson yeah
because when I watch him he had a moment
in that game 9:30 games by the way I
love them I love I like a football I
like a nice coffee the end of a daddy
cigar okay I'm kind of going this is
like an amuse-bouche this is an
appetizer for football but there was one
play where he is getting sacked and
somehow drops it off to like Duke
Johnson or something behind the line
behind the line and then afterwards he
did them
MJ shoulder shrug and then looked at
Darren fells I posted it on my handle at
Adam Lefko and then Darren fells kind of
looks back laughing Kyle you've seen
this before
when a player is around the star player
and goes Dan this [ __ ] crazy
you can't explain it and he is at that
level he is a top three quarterback in
this league hence Tim he made another
play where he's thrown the ball down the
fields getting tackled he's literally
coming he's almost on his knees throwing
the ball down the field complete till
Jordan jumped over somebody awesome
great athlete I hope that they could
figure out a way to protect them so you
can play as long
on the first time he makes big plays he
he's one of these guys and we talk about
elevators guys that can make everyone
around them better he makes everybody
offensive line looks much better even
though he gets tackled a bunch behind
the last challenge but he makes the
receivers make plays in the place that
the offensive lineman missed so he's
getting sacked getting tackled that he's
able to throw the ball behind him to
Duke Johnson to throw the ball down the
field as he's going down we see that
wherever watching and we're kind of like
that's a good play and then you're
watching they give you like you know
what that's not a good play that's a
great play by a great athlete by a guy
who continues to carry his football team
I there was so I like to look at game
flow and one of the things that I look
at when I'm in game betting shout-out to
jus Franklin made a lot of money
yesterday in game betting is I try and
ask is this sustainable mm-hmm so when
when I never really pay that much
attention to the first Drive because
those are typically scripted plays but
when it's the second quarter I'm going
which offensive lines getting the most
push if this T oh they got it they
scored because that was a big pass
interference that's probably not
sustainable to happen again I'm watching
that I'm seeing deshaun Watson under
attack in the first quarter and I was
going this is not sustainable it is not
sustainable for him to continuously
being under pressure in two seconds and
rolling out making plays but it is with
him yes it is well this is I I was
watching Tamar Jackson last night we
haven't talked about him yet but that's
really the same thing kind of applies to
the Shaun Watson and the thought process
when you have a franchise quarterback
you don't want to run too much because
he's gonna get hurt he's only gonna last
a short period of time you don't want to
do this cuz he's gonna take too many
hits I'm starting to think that the
thought process has to lean towards
Carla Marion and Russell Wilson and
deshaun Watson and and of course Lamar
Jackson is you know what we're gonna
ride this doggone horse until he's no
more until he can't do it anymore
whether there's five years whether
they're no you just you just keep riding
it because when you have a quarterback
like this when you talk about Lamar he's
on a different level but we have a
quarterback like that he does he makes
plays that no one else in the world can
make Lamar Jackson was the best athlete
on the field again I'm amongst great
athletes last night I know at the
quarterback position in the
that he's able to do can [ __ ] he's
getting up packing it up his run his hat
is ripping his chinstrap off
give me the play we'll get into that
game fully more but with Lamar Lamar is
faster than both then Russ and snow
Deshawn not even close Russell this is
when you talk about athletes you say
Deshawn you say Lamar Deshawn and then
Russell is like yes because he's not as
a good of an athlete I in terms of every
we always end up talking about how they
protect themselves
I find Russell to be the best at
protecting himself he always looks like
he's about to go down he's an expert
slider I never I never shudder when
Russell runs
Lamar is the one where I go it's in his
nature to try and put his shoulder down
he got hit one time last night and I was
like oh that's the hit but I'm not
worried about it like because my thing
with Lamar is it's very rare that
someone's gonna catch him right and also
he's been so good at getting out of
bounds his rookie year is when I head
towards the end where he would try and
lower a shoulder on a Bengal and I was
like those are the games where she gets
[ __ ] up but to Sean I'm more worried
about in the pocket getting yes
position he's always like pulling up or
or escaping and one time it's gonna be
like
coleus Campbell or Fletcher Cox and that
pull that's he's the one that scares
will when you're in the pocket a lot of
times you don't see those exactly those
are the ones that hurt you the most just
like in the fight you're getting the
fighting you get punching you don't see
the punch coming those are the ones that
hurt you Lamar sees them coming so it's
a little bit different cuz you can
prepare differently as a player I again
my point was that we may have to adjust
the way that we look at these franchise
quarterbacks though because I there's no
doubt in my mind I think Lamar Jackson
will continue to get better as a passer
but he can't he can't you can't keep
running like this your whole career can
you not not not eight years ten years
later I think I just think it's hard to
play at that level this way for that
period of time I think he can do it this
style for the next 3-4 years yes and
then I believe afterwards when Aaron
Rodgers was in his prime he was a guy
that would do the soul-crushing third
down scramble
and that's what I hope Lamar will have
the problem is is right now and I agree
with you you need to run this office
it's an offense that no one the NFL is
so dangerous I mean he's standing back
there with with a tight end on his right
a running back on his left and another
running back behind him and they're
doing the triple option and then they're
pulling a tight end across or they're
doing Hollywood Brown on a mesh concept
and and the defense is going okay I have
to guard my man I'm also worried about
them handing off and then the worst part
is the the most dangerous guy on their
offense is the guy that already has the
ball to begin with to run the ball Lamar
Jackson just think about that game and
we all have said this a million times
Bill Belichick takes away what you do
best it makes you operating with your
second I think that's taken away lesson
not last night you can't how do you take
that away I mean the defense this is a
key for a defense is understanding where
the play is gonna go and be in there
before the offense can get there right
and so last night what you saw as
defensive lineman crossing the line of
scrimmage and guessing they didn't know
who had the ball they didn't know which
direction did the ball was going in they
liked it they knew Lamar Jackson had the
ball at one point they couldn't catch
him I mean it was it was a thing of
beauty to watch that all things last
night we talked about this Patriots
defense for the first eight weeks it's
okay we apparently have a colbrunn Lamar
Jackson hello so Lamar who is left go I
just wanted to say that everything that
happened against the Ravens this week
was totally by design bro Belichick
wanted Lamar Jackson to scramble for all
those yards so when they meet up in the
playoffs too it Johnny haba is gonna be
like all remember how Lamar scramble for
all those yards against the Patriots
back in November let's try that strategy
again kid and then Jonte Hightower is
gonna rep you a pat in the backfield for
a 30 yard loss dude Kyle van Noy bro do
you even notice how Belichick spent all
week blowing smoke up Justin tuck his
ass and then Tucker missed that easy
field goal that was all mind games it
was an extra point not a field shut up
Trevor
why off you can fumble the ball to give
the game away huh Edelman's literally
never fumbled in his entire life bro
that was actually his 24th career fall
shut up Trevor anyway we're eight and
one now which is exactly what Belichick
intended remember it's chase wina vich
not chase loser [ __ ] Pat Pat oh wow
that's that's about that's Pat Pat
pat pat there it is yes it's pat but
he's a pat the Patriots got dominated at
the mana screaming this is what Patriots
fans are saying though huh they're going
Oh Patriots they need that loss
Belichick once this he wants to motivate
them oh yeah once Belichick sees your
blueprint in week one he's doing this to
just get ready for you for the playoffs
that's an easy answer but it also is
allowed you're right I think a lot of
Patriots feel Patriots fans appeal that
was like I heard Simmons he was like
this is perfect this is when everybody
starts down the Patriots and I and I
want to go know that usually happens in
week five like week five is like when
they're figuring it out this was just
the Ravens came in off of a bye with a
phenomenal game plan and we knew that
the Patriots Achilles heel the defense
to this point had been allowing rushing
yards we saw that with Cleveland Browns
and Nick Chubb if he didn't fumble they
would have amassed a ton of yards but
the thing is is you I can simultaneously
go the Ravens beat the [ __ ] out of them
and expose some weaknesses on that
defense and then also go Belichick is
probably gonna figure this out and other
teams are gonna try and take advantage
of it it's not going to work and now I'm
looking at Brian Westbrook shaking his
head and I'm realizing dear God I could
be sitting at a table right now with a
guy that actually believes the Patriots
are gonna crumble and so I cautiously
turn this over to you well here's what I
think I think that you can figure it out
I mean in any game you could figure out
where to be but at some point there
comes a point where you have to say I
have to make a play against a better
athlete and there was plenty of times
last night they had Lamar Jackson dead
sir is right right there they had him
and just couldn't tackle him he was too
elusive he was too quick he was too fast
they just couldn't take him down and
listen I think Bill Belichick came with
a good game plan it was a great game
plan however they got hit in the mouth
by offensive line that was dominant they
got hitting him out without by a running
game but my current Mark Ingram running
downhill he was dominant and Lamar
Jackson just finished it off with
outside runs different ball handling not
know where the ball was going to go how
do you think it's a run oh no we're
dumping over the top so fast that's the
Patriots moving forward well I think
that they had an easy schedule the first
half of the season oh my and now I think
they're facing much tougher teams the
second half I'm not saying that they're
gonna collapse and things like that
think that they have a much tougher
schedule and it won't be as easy as it
looked early on I think Bill Belichick
has a bye week they face Philadelphia
there both of those teams are customers
we're gonna get [ __ ] slaughter that's
gonna be so angry yeah
like ah it's almost like someone else
cheated on the test and now we're all
getting punished for it that's right and
Lamar is the cheat code now like the
Eagles we're gonna be the team that Bill
Belichick destroys because there's no
other quarterback in this league that
can do with Lamar Jackson did last night
and it was amazing
it might this is what I thought the
Patriots gonna do and this was kind of
what they did against us and Donovan
wasn't a running quarterback like Lamar
any means but I thought they were going
to be like a picket fence at the
offensive line of scrimmage defensive
line of scrimmage and just not present
any holes because what happens is if the
defensive line get at different levels
right so if you have the two inside
tackles at the line of scrimmage and you
have the D ends of the field because
they're trying to get to the quarterback
there's a gap there they're at different
levels you're able to make em and make
some moves and get into those holes if
you just have a picket fence where no
one's getting any penetration now you
just gotta find a hole and it's harder
to do that that's what I thought they
were gonna do yeah however when you had
that ball handling the tricky ball
handling guys get out of place when you
can do a handoff to the running back
yeah fullback you introduce a jet sweep
and then you have an athlete like Mark
Andrews over the top and Lamar you can
get slice and dice six different way
it's just hard to defend it and you
can't be right because what he's gonna
say is that oh you're taking that okay
I'm gonna hold the ball oh you're not
taking away this I'm gonna hand it off
and then you do a lot of different
things from it it's just hard to compete
like that I will also say that that was
the first game in which we saw Jimmy
Smith Humphries heaters in the field
together yes an Earl Thomas flying
around I mean that was real Thomas's
best game of the year for me the Ravens
were firing on all cylinders their
offense knew exactly what it was doing
and I think when you play what you were
saying it's like standing every gap the
way you beat it is you destroy those
people yeah and and you don't try and
run around them you run through them and
the Ravens mark Gus Edwards runs like
that Mark Ingram runs like that Willie
Sneed plays like that a little more
Jackson kind of plays like that I will
say though that the NFL it's so fickle
how a game can be a blowout or really
close
Thursday night for example this was
Arizona taking on San Francisco
the undefeated San Francisco 49ers San
Francisco is up 10 they have the ball
they're trying to go down the field they
call a perfectly time screen pass to
Tevin Coleman on third down Tevin
Coleman is so excited to turn upfield
because he has two blockers and no
defenders that he drops the ball it
would have been an 80 yard touchdown the
Niners go up 17 game over the Niners we
go into next week go and not only they
know they're beating the crap out of
team steady drops it Cardinals get the
ball back three plays later Andy
Isabella who had three catches all year
88-yard touchdown because he's a track
star at am at umass touchdown it's a
three-point game
and now the Internet's going up the
Niners crawling to a win over the 3 4
and 1 Cardinals last night this could go
either way but the Patriots
so there's the Ravens get the fumble
recovery touchdown they go up 24 213 the
Patriots drive down the field get a
touchdown it is 24 to 20 and I'm sitting
there going Patriots come here they come
later Eco but Manny
I thought the Ravens have been great but
they still haven't done it enough the
Ravens go on eight like 11 play
eight-minute drive but on that drive if
you remember there was a third and five
where Lamar lobs it up to Mark Andrews
who jumps over one of the mccurdy
brothers and makes the catch incredible
50/50 play then fourth and four they go
for it on the 38 and they get Willie
Snead on the sideline who turns it up
and then the drive ends with that crazy
Lamar play where he drops back
levan Noah has him dead to right he
literally steps to the left and runs it
down to the two and they score but on
that drive you have a 50/50 ball to
David and to Mark Andrews you have I
have a friend named David engine lob to
to Mark Andrews then a fourth and four
to Snead and then it becomes 30 to 20
because they missed the extra point but
they win this game by 17 but if either
of those plays don't happen
goes the other way I would bet all of my
money that the Patriots win that game
and that's why for me I don't the
Patriots were in that game I thought the
most satisfying thing is a non Patriots
fan was watching Tom Brady on the bench
during the second 10-minute Drive that
put him up 37 20 where he was sitting
there yelling at him so and he's like
pulling his beautiful hair out and you
just see the pain that he's under
granted
I'm sorry Patriots fans but for me that
was so sad as refreshing Oh see him on
the sidelines during a 10-play Drive oh
well you know what was refreshing and
this is and I'll tell you this you go
into the game against the Patriots a you
make any mistakes
you will lose period Jones fumble
although the muffed punt side their own
23 no way that the Ravens can win now
and they did at this point I think the
score was with 17 to 3 something Crazy's
like 17 nothing and I'm like yep reg
wasn't gonna lose those two mistakes
right there then the Patriots who never
make mistakes right now Julia Edelman
fumble puts it on the ground first a
first career ever according to pat pat
yeah pat pat thank you buddy but it's
weird but it also kind of shows you that
their offense where the Patriots is
still not quite right but you know what
else I saw yesterday James White
continues to be a baller that nobody
talks about sorry Mohamed Sanu
is a legitimate wide receiving option
Adelman is still gonna Adelman and he's
gonna be great and I look at the I look
at them Birkhead is now healthy he's a
weapon but I do think the Patriots need
either a Dorsett or a Meyer or somebody
to really step up well their office a
lot of the liability and that's gonna
get in a bye week coming and hopefully
Isaiah wind guys come back they're
starting tackle they can get some help
there I have I have no doubt in the
Patriots but I will say this and I said
it before the year the Ravens are now
one step closer to maybe getting that
home-field advantage
mhm I [ __ ] called that and I want to
take my victory lap right and gonna take
a look can I take it
take a lap why wouldn't you do you
believe Brian Westbrook after all that
talk in the first two weeks that the
Baltimore Ravens are a true Super Bowl
contender
they certainly I think that
to me listen they have what which you
would think his a Super Bowl team is
made up I tell you right now last night
they look great again you also you got a
save it you lock this is what you've got
to be weary of and this li this is a
part that concerns me tell me anytime
you have a running quarterback Oh an
ankle injury happens all the time
and I never wish to injury on you that's
what you you have to be concerned with
and don't do that anymore quarterback
know that running is what listen if I
had a team right now I would it would be
hard for me to not take a running
quarterback over a pocket passing
quarterback right because you get an
advantage that almost there's 32 teams
and there may be three or four running
quarterback that can do something
similar I want that type of advantage
I'm with their army maybe whoever runs
the triple option in college type of
advantage that's what the Ravens had the
thing with Lamar to is he went 30 second
to the Ravens you knew who traded with
the Ravens to get that pick who's a
Eagles because we had won the Super Bowl
mm-hmm but you look at now the guys
taken in front of him Josh Rosen is on
milk cartons yeah people are trying to
save him from wherever he is Jets fans
right now are saying not only are the
Jets awful but that Sam darn 'old
regressing they're saying that he's
gotten worse than last year
Baker Mayfield shaved his facial hair
three times in the game he walked in
with a beard he played with a foo Manchu
he ended with a mustache and at every
press conference he looks like he's
doing a hostage do these stories like
please save me and the only other one is
Josh Allen who every time I watch a
Bills game he's a great athlete but
Lamar is a better athlete and Lamar is a
better thrower than him too I was a big
kid he's a big kid that's fine but I
look and it's there were all these
questions about Lamar and now in this
all-time five quarterback class not only
is it not close its undebatable well you
know the only one you could argue for
right now is Josh Allen and it's not a
debate because he's not a better athlete
and that was what he's known for now
know the Marge actions the best one that
class the Grateful area is a great thing
that you've seen is the fact that do
their office go to Greg Roman
yes
that he didn't try to change Lamar
Jackson he didn't try to turn him into
something that he's not he said this is
what this kid is good at and he's not
not only good at he's great at what he
does and he just does it over and over
and we're just going to give the defense
a lot of different things to look at
motions and different hands ball
handling things like that they didn't
try to change them our Jackson and again
I would take me a running style of
quarterback that has that ability
because when you're young sometimes
you're passing just it takes time to
catch up all those guys you just
mentioned they're passing these time to
catch up if you have that type of
ability escape ability in the pocket the
ability to run the football be the best
athlete on the field you can win games
with that early on in your career and
you hope that as your career gets longer
in age that you can say you know what I
became a much better passer now I don't
have to lean on my wheels anymore to try
to win football games
- comparisons that I have that I want
your take on mm-hmm Lamar Jackson versus
Michael Vick who's more dangerous Mike
was so fast but Michael Vick was a fast
track like type of speed right in at
that time he was dangerous because he
had a rocket for are much stronger arm
than Lamar Jackson he had these faster
than Lamar Jackson like you think so and
a 40 I think though I think Mike Vick
with him alone but Lamar Jackson has
make you miss skills that Michael Vick
doesn't have he found him to be a little
bit more loose he's more elusive than
Michael Vick he can make you miss he
make him pay - and I think the office
that they're running I also think Lamar
has a little bit more touch you think so
I think like the little flip and a
little Dinks and dunks cuz that was
always my issue with Mike I told Lamar
Jackson in his office a Goose's guy in
the back he almost did a couple time
which is hilarious to me but I think he
might you would which one would you take
I think I'm taking Lamar's always always
what have you done for me lately so you
see that now but I think I would take
Lamar but especially with this offense
and some play they were trying to make
Michael Vick like more of a pocket type
of pass feel like when he got out of
prison and went back to the Eagles they
kind of sat him in the pocket he also
lost a step and I mean he still can run
he's still gonna run but he just wasn't
the same type of an eye I would agree
with what you're saying - is you know he
had
maura Jim Mora Jew yes yeah and that's
been proven we see what he is and Greg
Romans history in this league the best
years of Tyrod Taylor the best years of
Colin Kapernick and now this and also he
worked with Anthony little a little bit
of a buffalo his running concepts are
what's so great it's it's not just
sitting back there and coming out with
like dagger cross or figuring out mesh
concepts he's like what if I have the
full-back go left but I block with a
running like that's some next-level [ __ ]
and with Lamar when you established that
and then you have a guy like Hollywood
Brown yes and Mark Andrews Mark Andrews
is a mismatch for any safety or
linebacker and Hollywood Brown you get
him on an underneath route yeah and you
we saw this with Stephon Gilmore last
night come on Gilmore the best quarter
in the NFL if you have to chase
Hollywood Brown under traffic hard to do
that and Lamar could just sit there one
two that's 20 yards it's hard to do it
it's just hard to do that I appreciate
what he's been able to do again when you
have this hyper quarterback the
longevity is always the concern I think
you ride this thing just keep riding it
and if the wheels fall off in wheel six
I mean in year six cool we had a great
run and hopefully you win a couple of
Super Bowls during that time yeah I'm if
I'm a GM I'm no longer looking for I
need a guy for 10 12 years I need a guy
that can make me win right now for the
second ball has some longevity if we
can't but I want him to win right now
for the next five six years so the one
guy that does both and we didn't talk
about at all yet the MVP and is likely
the favorite of the MVP right now his
old freakin Russell Wilson ol reliable
Russ
Russell Wilson averaged an eight point
five yards of throw 22 touchdowns two
one interception highest QB rating in
the NFL at 118 point two and yet again
against the Tampa Bay Bucs when the run
games not clicking and the defense is
allowing 30 points yeah let's give the
ball to Russ and him and Tyler Lockett
are gonna make magic
they are Russell Russell Wilson and
Tyler Lockett is the best quarterback
wide receiver duo in the NFL prove me
wrong I don't need to hear about wide
receivers that are bigger I don't
need to hear about quarterbacks that are
more accurate that connection is
undefeated he puts it up he brings it in
you wants lamps you want goes you want
screams you want pitches Russell Wilson
and Tyler Lockett the number one
combination in quarterback wide receiver
in the sport
prove me wrong well I can go with you
there I can go with you I mean I can
make a couple arguments but I certainly
can believe that
I think Russell Wilson has the best
touch of any quarterback in the league
he throws some of the prettiest videos
the easiest balls to catch it's almost
like a pillow you just boom falls right
into your arms
he puts just enough loft on it that the
receiver can run underneath it but the
defense can't get to it yes it's just
it's a thing of beauty
we had a quarterback who is it Jeff
blank he threw the best deep balls let
me just do it deep ball a nice tight
spiral but just landed right here nice
and pretty
same thing that Russell Wilson does and
Russell puts it into place only the wide
receiver can get to it the deep back has
no chance to get into the football it's
gonna be a touchdown or is gonna be an
incomplete not an interception and it's
weird because we look at you like this
is a lollipop pass well I was a ball
going so high in the air and then next
thing you know oh there goes title lock
it underneath it catching a football
there goes Metcalfe underneath it
catching the football in a great game by
him Josh Gordon that's my thing is when
the when the steel can be hope can you
help that team right now
you think because for me when the
Seahawks were clicking they had their
small guy that handled everything which
was Doug Baldwin back in the day and
then they had their bigger guys that
jermaine curses they had Chris Matthews
in the one Superbowl game but and then
they had like Jimmy Graham so now if you
have lock it underneath and Gordon and
Metcalfe physical specimens each of them
on the outside that can handle any gym
the only issue with Gordon is he's a
note he's not a noted run blocker which
DK Metcalfe has shown to be pretty good
at right but Russell Wilson we just
talked about throws great 50/50 balls
and that's what Josh Gordon can give you
and so if you have the 50/50 balls with
Chris Carson in that screen game and the
connection with Tyler Lockett where's
Carson had a good game yes my only issue
with the Seahawks is they allowed 34 the
Bucs
20 of the Falcons 30 the Ravens 28 to
the Browns 29 of the Rams 33 to the
Saints 26 to the Steelers 20 of the
Bengals Stephens hot garbage
yes and so I looked at there's two teams
that Warren kind of found have been
exceeding their expectations that are
currently in the playoffs but the rest
of their schedule gets a lot harder and
they could fall off and those two teams
yesterday and they were the Seahawks and
the Vikings and I think we that makes
sense we can look at those two teams and
both of them yesterday there they were
in a game in which it came down to their
quarterback and only one of them had
Russell Wilson the Vikings taking on the
Chiefs great opportunity to win the game
had beyond opportunities I mean oh I
wrote this down Dan Bailey misses an
extra point yeah because he missed that
extra point they're down 24 to 20
instead of 24 to 21 that's right and so
then they have to go for the end zone
instead of kick in the field goal it
[ __ ] up their whole plans but I looked
at those two games and the Vikings
towards the end
couldn't keep drives going I watched
Seahawks bucks
Russell Wilson keeps drives going
there's a difference and so those teams
I think will both slightly disappoint in
the second half but Russ is gonna keep
this team going and Kirk is a very good
quarterback but he ain't even close in
critical situations that's the big
question about Kirk Cousins I got a
couple stats on that but I wanted to
point out and you kind of you gotta both
ways when this stat about Russell Wilson
I you said well you know Seattle Dave
for one oh they're all their games are
like close games and you know what they
say about those runs to me I feel like
you know of course you don't want any
game to be close but what I think this
these close games build especially when
you win them it builds a mentally tough
football team if it builds the type of
team like Pete Carroll once because in
the playoffs they're gonna be close
games I have lost so much money on the
Seahawks because I've always thought
they're overrated but there's game
situational awareness and laughs and his
ability to perform incredible foot it
always there's not a lot of guys and I
think Kirk Cousins is a great example
there's not a lot of guys that you can
say there's two minutes left on the game
and
I'm gonna give you the ball there are
guys that say you know what I had a good
game I've got 150 yards already I'm good
on this this is not my time in the
godson Russell Wilson Aaron Rodgers
you're the boss of those leaves you get
the ball to those guys because they're
gonna get it well and put carson wentz
in that not yet wouldn't not yet Kirk
Cousins now yeah no no they haven't done
in - no they haven't done if at all I
can't remember a time that Carson
Winston said you know what I'm gonna go
drive the ball down the field maybe a
couple times I mean it's Sunday I mean
yesterday they were up and he was that
was the scenery gauge rod they ran a
ball weld there there parses it against
the Rams when he tore his ACL yeah it's
not consistently like Russell Wilson has
no I think Russell is the prime example
of how you win football games
close game you know the best part who's
that next Monday night Seahawks at
Niners how you feel about their seven
and to see hogs 8 no Niners I think it's
it's the Niners with extra rest because
they played on Thursday Kyle Shannon
with extra rest is kind of crazy my
initial thoughts are now we get to see
Russ take on a really good defense when
I also do it's like the Bucs defense
good run defense shitty pass defense
Falcons one of the worse that there ever
is Ravens it was the first game with
Peters so it was kind of all over the
place Browns defense hasn't been great
but this is gonna be it's gonna be a
great test for both teams we're gonna
learn a lot of and I love the fact that
it's Richard Sherman on the other side
taking us forward yes that's beautiful
it's just beautiful story I think that
the Seahawks defense gets us both
unfortunately been exposed I think they
are Jameis Winston doesn't fumble
exposed even more though I mean I'm
talking we're talking about this team is
one of the best teams in the NFC right
now and for their defense to be playing
the way that they're playing against you
know you should be given up 34% of the
Bucks here's the thing the Rams are
[ __ ] creepin 5 & 3
we got a buy this week yeah Seahawks are
7 & 2
mm-hmm Seahawks play at Niners let's say
it's a loss ok let's say it's loss it's
in San Francisco K 7 and 3 here be fair
yeah by at Philadelphia that's a total
I'm telling ya then if Philly could put
up some points against that defense
then home against the Vikings tough and
and Kirk Cousins has won in season
before at the Rams another tough one at
the Panthers another tough one and then
it's home against the Cardinals that's a
Niners means they're gonna tub they have
a very tough schedule I'm just saying
that the NFC West because the Rams we
know will be able to fight till the end
and we do have faith in the Niners when
you factor that in it could be
interesting there might be AI you hear
that you're either getting three teams
at the NFC West or one team very
distinct you get three out of in and see
West but also the Vikings and the
Packers you got the Saints in there and
the pair I kind of feel like the the
Saints will get in Panthers won't
Vikings I just feel like the NFC West
should have three come on I mean I just
kind of feel that one big thing for
playoffs is going to be home-field
advantage and that's what one of our
other dolphin tanks is this week so
let's get to them before we get things
about this this is what I wanted to
mention nothing we've kind of touched it
already these close games that they've
had already it's gonna lead the way to
that tough end of the year schedule for
that for the for the Seahawks they're
making something they're building
something Pete Carroll is constantly
mentally challenging these guys
physically challenged these guys they're
building something out there yeah and DK
Metcalf is getting pretty he's getting
better
she's getting better oh he looks he's
getting better all right let's do it oh
man out there
and finally into the tank left goes got
an AFC team that's actually hoping to
just barely sneak into the playoffs and
not even attempt to get a first-round
bye
because their home crowds are just that
lousy local fans have been bolting
toward the exits all year long as
they're discussed with their favorite
team could fill up several rivers with
their nauseated vomiting because their
team just can't seem to derp win any
home James
I mean games who are they let's find out
[Music]
invar does not send these to me ahead of
time he doesn't and there's so much
better when I hear them they're pretty
cool though ah that's a great job yes so
I'm saying there's this team in the AFC
West that you know they could be a lot
better but their home field advantage
stinks mm-hmm and so what you're buying
here is that this home-field advantage
is a huge part of this team's failure
okay I mean he gave you a lot of Nuggets
well yeah I mean it sounds like the
Chargers however you guys are kind of
tricky with these you've been very very
tricky I will say that so a say that
this team in the AFC West at home they
have a losing record under 500 on the
road therefore and oh so what I'm
suggesting is maybe this team should
just play all road games yes maybe they
should Oakland we have three guests is
Oakland the Chargers obviously can why
are you doubting us because you guys are
kind of tricky about this and then
Denver all three of those teams one at
home and Kent they can't stay to their
home yeah their home so all for the team
yeah one at home it was lucky for this
team
lucky yeah barely pulled it up barely
paled it out let's go Denver so are you
buying that the home-field advantage
they have they have bad home-field
advantage
I think Oakland is bad home-field
advantage to quite honestly yeah I think
you just bought the Chiefs have shitty
home-field advantage I'll say this he's
on to us David we need to adjust yes you
guys are kind of tricky there no this is
what's so funny about the Chiefs before
Sunday they were 1 & 3 at home
I and and David said this to me before
he goes you know there's two places that
you assume have the best home-field
advantage
Seattle in Kansas City Kansas City right
now two and three at home and Seattle
right now is three and two at home so
they were two and two heading into
yesterday it's just funny because you
know if you're talking to the average
person they're gonna go Arrowhead really
too [ __ ] tough place to play
well they lose though because they lost
to the Colts which was the game with
mahomes that was with mahomes but that
was like the really good jacobi percent
could forty minutes then it was against
the Texans where deshaun Watson kind of
controlled it and then one game with
Matt Moore on Monday night football
against the Packers where he played
great yeah I lost you know it's just
more of it this is not a take I'm not
saying Chiefs fans stink I'm not saying
that their home field isn't really good
I'm just curious
we always thought ever had was this
tough ass place to play why are they
losing more games we're really really
loud there so it is it does get out
there it gets nasty I'll see if red
obviously a big deal there I think
getting Chris Jones back makes a big
difference in that great oh my I saw him
play I don't know through his last year
the year before against the eagle and he
just was all over the place he's big
he's nasty he's strong he makes
everybody in that defensive line better
that's that's why I get so angry these
last two weeks not to harp on this and
be like nananana poopoo I was right but
like that's why these last two weeks
have people have been like man the
Vikings and the Packers and we're able
to do whatever they want against this
bad she's Steve indifferent and I'm like
the mahomes the defense isn't playing
that's right that's how important Chris
Jones is big difference yeah he plays
like 80% of me he saw I was watching
yesterday and he's like pushing a guard
in the center bat like five six yards in
the backfield and he looks like a giant
of man he looks much bigger than
everyone else like proportionate yeah
and like he's got one of those days
where those guys has like a tiny head
and a huge Nonnie
mm-hmm but no but so have you ever
played in Kansas City I have some of the
best barbecue listen they're so nice
after the game this is the only place it
ever happen and this has nothing to do
this but I think
came they give you barbecue they have
this in the locker room
Derek Thomas's mom has like a whole
tailgate section there they give you
barbecue and I here take the barbecue to
the playing don't don't worry about
those nasty hamburgers or hot dogs that
the team gives you yeah I think this
nice barbecue pool pulled pork and ribs
and that's how easy it is to whenever
Westbrook it was just hand I'm old if
you get some food that's it
let's go smoke yeah it was great close
yes but listen I don't think I
appreciate that but winning their stuff
it gets loud there usually it's a little
chilly little cold and I think as his
defense gets better which I don't know
that their how much better they're gonna
get but having Chris Jones back
certainly plays a big part of it I think
that the fact that this team lost my
homes with an injury in which his
kneecap was on the side of his leg and
that it happened in the Broncos game and
they were able to win that game beat the
Vikings and then also almost like hang
with the Packers it has given me so much
more confidence in the Chiefs moving
forward because I you wonder with a
trans sent during a transcendent talent
like Patrick mahomes how much is he
responsible for how many of the mistakes
is he kind of making a lot but I think
what's great is we saw this with Wentz
and foals when the guy goes down and I
would say my home's going down right now
felt like when my when whence went down
the year where he was like the MVP
leader where you're kind of like wow
he's the guy right and you watch the
offensive line stepup Sammy Watkins is
now playing with a little at least play
a little bit of hurt but he's playing
well Tyree kills getting into form the
defense is coming alive and now mahomes
was going to be back next year he will
be playing at Tennessee and I'm just
letting you know that now that the team
kind of can look around and go we can
win without mahomes how [ __ ] nasty
can we be with mahomes there's something
about that that gets me really excited
for this Chiefs team moving forward you
should be you should be excited the
other thing that gets me excited as a
shorter guy I'm 510 whoo it's all right
Tyreke here five one five ten what are
you saying
magton I'm saying that if you want to
bring out the rule we could try it's not
five two five ten ish but it's great to
watch to wreak ill wearing temps I am
wearing - I'm wearing definitely - inner
soles oh you're so about Tyree killed
going up and not only is he's the
fastest because there's a lot of fast
guys in the NFL no one's faster than him
but there's a lot of fast guys in the
NFL that normally can't catch there's a
lot of guys that can run good route but
they don't have speed but they don't
have speed or there's a lot of guys have
speed but they're not quick but here's
one of these guys usually you say 50/50
ball DK Metcalf you're the bigger guys
Julio yeah you know the big guys he goes
and gets the 50 feels it for being
everybody he wins them all just jumps
over top of him he tracks the ball will
then he just jumps over top of you how's
that tell you about the Damian Williams
touchdown where he's sorry that was
wrong and then Tyreke Hill out rat-like
the quarter that was wrong the quarters
give it everything and Tyree killed Sean
Jackson did that to me am I in in
Minnesota one year Wow game-winning
touchdown on the screen play in
Minnesota I think it might have been the
playoffs I'm running I'm going as fast
as I can
Jackson comes flying past me just like
that he's not tarik hills faster than
dogs when Sean Jackson into both
Lightning when I talked to guys that are
on his team and like every now and then
I'll [ __ ] around and be like is this guy
faster than Tyree and they're like bro
stop asking this question so fast nobody
so quick he's one of the only guys that
when I interview NFL players and his
name come up his name comes up they like
feel the need to touch me and go he's
fast and I want to go I know but it's
the way they say it yeah it's like you
need to see it did you see where he
started at on that play I know
50 yards behind him and then ran and got
him I miss it's hard and then you have
Hardman to like he's fast he gotta hold
on to the doggone ball but no but I look
at the Chiefs and I go at Titans that's
a win so now they move to seven and
three they play the Chargers twice and
I'm not gonna lie
Chargers cut another they all scary
offensively they have me I still like
Mike Williams I mean big shark is fast
I like Keenan Islands same type of thing
big strong and fast Melvin Gordon seems
like he's finally got into Shane's back
yeah I mean they got some guys that can
play and listen Philip Rivers will throw
the best jump balls in the league he
just puts it up there for those six four
receivers just go get it and and puts it
over to Melbourne yeah he just alright
well here you know what I Melvin Gordon
is good I put out a question on a
Twitter pretty much saying just what
questions do you have for us one a
twitter twitter and i just so i wanted
to hear from you guys because it's been
a long time since we've taken questions
so we'll start off here cuz we were just
talked about this game from Brody Meyer
at 13 Meyer bro Aaron Rodgers who how
about them bolts everyone hates on in
parentheses there's like five of us fans
in existence so let us have this that
game was the the fluky game of the week
weird game you know cuz you just look at
Aaron Rodgers getting Davante Adams back
that offense has been clicking but here
comes Joey Bosa here comes Melvin Ingram
don't look now but Derwin James
apparently is getting close to returning
they got some other safeties getting
healthy their best left tackle Russell
Okuma is playing now Melvin Gordon looks
like he's hitting his stride this is a
Chargers team that I've already written
off like I've already been like they're
not making it to the playoffs you have
to worry about it right now they're four
and five right and they're not that far
out nope nope well this is what they did
they fire their offensive coordinator
which is just I hate that [ __ ] you know
sometimes sometimes you got to do things
as a team just to get the guys just to
stir the pot a little me get the guys
going
and obviously that helped just a bit
Phillip Rivers play like a whole
different league well straight well
yesterday got the ball out of his hands
but the Chargers won the game at the
line of scrimmage they dominated at the
line of scrimmage all fencing and
defensive line you know the other thing
when you watch the game we talked about
Keenan Allen and Mike Williams the one
who the 50/50 balls one-on-one battles
they wanted every last one of them and
we were talking about the the Packers
defense secondary in particular early on
in the season and we were saying the DS
guy
a great Dean hasn't the best secondary
we've seen in a long time great defense
and they got dominated yesterday by some
pretty good receiver something that I'm
not really surprised let's dominate
yesterday
so the first three games of the year the
Packers allowed 35 points and everybody
was crowning them including myself as a
great defense you look back now and
realize they did this to the Bears
Vikings and Joe Flacco and the Broncos
and you go okay then you look at their
last six games they allowed 26 to the
Chargers Matt Moore the Chiefs put up 24
the raiders moved the ball pretty well
but Aaron Rodgers had an all time game
at the Raider scored 20 for the Lions
had 22 and they got jobs out of that
game by a few bad penalty calls the
Cowboys put up 24 the Eagles beat them
with 34 so the first three games you
couldn't course score 17 no since then
no team has scored below 22 and you know
they play the Panthers next week and
they have a bye
I still believe in the pact right I
still do quietly the story of the season
has has to be who did you play and how
good were they at that time because
there's a bunch of teams Cowboys the
Packers you know there's other teams the
Patriots like who did you play early on
the season you're eight no okay well now
you have to play a real team you have to
play a real football think about this
Green Bay 18 plays in the first half it
was one of the best quarterbacks in the
history of the game 18 plays on the
average you're gonna get 3035 plays in
the first half of a football game and
the weird part about the game for Green
Bay is that when you get blown out like
like they did 26 to 15 2016 11 excuse me
it felt worse than it felt worse but
they didn't turn the ball over so you
think when you get blown out like that
you turn the ball over no fumbles no
interceptions
it's just they just got a beat and Aaron
Rodgers made a point to say this after
the game you know what maybe you know
with the way they were seven and one at
the time maybe our heads got a little
bit too big this is a humbling
experience for us it's a go to LA and
get beat like this in LA that is
humbling so I think the Packers come
back hungrier I also think that they try
to get the ball to Davante Adams and
went away from what they did best
they're only down by nine at halftime
they were getting the ball to the
running backs yeah out of the backfield
catching the ball they were running the
football
and they got to try to find a balance
between getting the ball to Adams and
running the football and having some
balance with those guys in the backfield
as well
it's the AFC West is interesting to me
because like Broncos win with Brandon
Allen who should literally look crazy yo
Lindsey is one of the more entertaining
guys the NFL fan chargers get a win that
no one was expecting Chiefs hold off the
Vikings and the Raiders the Raiders go
out there and and put up another great
offensive game with the AeroGarden Jon
Gruden and savage Raider at s black 1984
asks me and you very simply
are you buying into the Raiders this is
not a dolphin tank just a normal
question are you buying the Raiders
right now I would and I'll tell you I'll
tell you why by the way yesterday was
our first home game since week two has
been a long time I think that Derek Carr
is playing better than he has since
probably he hurt his leg a few years
back I think they have a legitimate
running back in Josh Jacobs 120 yards
yesterday I think that as a receiving
corps they can get enough guys involved
to to finally make it make sense and
then they'll go draft the receiver this
year I think Darren was at Waller out
there while Ortiz it's been great yeah
he's been great nothing deep do not [ __ ]
on Hunter Renfro I've always been good
to he's been good balding white guys
dream I like catches the football and
does everything the coaches gas room he
has a very deliberate spill of the two
they have to find they got to find an
explosive player and they'll find that
don't find that in the draft next couple
years
well that was supposed to be Antonio
Brown of course they defensively they're
nasty they're physical and they get out
their secondaries well yeah well next
year we're not so they're not going this
year but they get a bronze back next
year that brings an attitude that brings
a culture that brings nastiness I would
buy the Raiders absolutely my thing is
to about this year so right now they're
four and four as we mentioned the
Chargers are four and five AFC South as
a mess AFC North the only wild card
option other than the Ravens when the
vision will be the Steelers and they're
four and four so technically the Raiders
are like right there fighting for that
six I hope they still play the Bengals
at home that's a win they still play at
the Jets that feels like a win
they also play the Broncos still now
they do it to play the Chargers twice
the Titans but the Bengals and the Jets
I look at and go not every team has them
on their schedule right
the Raiders are a team right now that
when you look look at their last few
games they out dual Matt Stafford and
Alliance who's been playing great may
lose to deshaun Watson where they led
that entire game and deshaun Watson
makes an incredible play with one eye to
beat them Aaron Rodgers has not just the
greatest game of the season but
statistically the greatest game of his
career against them they beat the Bears
in London they beat the Colts in
Indianapolis they're only bad loss was
the Vikings the Chiefs came they lost in
week two the Chiefs called all their
points in the second quarter the Raiders
are one of these teams right now that we
have a lot of teams like that our bet
that are not as good as the record says
they are the Raiders for me or the
poster child of being better than the
record actually is they're up-and-coming
teen in there building the right wing
and listen I know a lot of people have
got upset about the Khalil Mak trade but
you get a bunch of picks back you
weren't ready to win at that point and I
think these pits over the next few years
they started to make sense you started
to get better and better more talent on
your team you this team has already has
some good building blocks already this
is a good football team they'll continue
to win and hopefully to move to Vegas
will help these guys win more games and
get a home-field advantage that we're
talking about that's what I've been
curious is because if you live in Vegas
everyone that lives in Vegas doesn't
Vegas you know what I mean yeah the
people that are local they go if you
want a good tie spot off the strip show
you and then like but when you go you go
hey thanks for the recommendation at the
same point I'm trying to be on the
street yeah I need to be mr. so really
it could be this great advantage because
all the visiting teams are like bottle
service and Hakkasan will meet me there
and the Raiders are like I already know
all the bottle people and I know a lot
of promoters and I'm not interested in
seeing snoop for the 80th time it could
turn into like that Miami advantage
just imagine the old-school coaches like
Andy Reid sending his team to Vegas to
play the Raiders and saying listen don't
leave the hotel there was one point we
went to San Francisco
Andy Reid told us in the meeting listen
we're going out on Friday I don't want
you guys gonna shopping I don't want you
guys doing anything immediately after
the meeting everybody stayed there short
Vinson said I want to talk to everybody
he said let's let me tell you something
we're all grown men you can do whatever
you want if you want to go shopping go
do that but I mean it still it's that if
you go to Vegas it ain't about shopping
it's about having some fun and right
about that potassium bag the next looks
funny did you see
so the Rockets played in Miami on Sunday
yes and there was a travel day on
Saturday so they're off and they started
they were start off the game down 40
points mhm and everybody was like that's
what happens when you have a Saturday
off of mine that's right and Vegas could
get like that too especially because
everything's kind of in walking distance
I don't know if you're a team you guys
no way you can stay on the chart on this
trip if you're a team there's no way
that you say I think they stay Pro we
got to stay 30 minutes outside of the
city
there's no way I would allow my team to
stay anywhere closer to staying at the
Caesars no no no no no I don't want you
gambling I don't want you in the little
you know the little shady closed down
and else he's throwing some crowd oh no
no no give me six oh hey guys it got
crazy it's some games we went to going
to Vegas would get on a whole different
level so I think you'd be a huge
advantage I believe something great all
right this one comes in from David
impact a KA at Swiss Dave 81 lef koe man
and the Rocket Man Chris Wessling from
the NFL Network shout-out to the heroes
of around the NFL has said he sees a
little bit of Brian Westbrook in Devin
Singletary of the Buffalo Bills does
Brian see that too
thanks from a UK Eagles fan shoutout to
London I love Singletary's game he's
tough he's hard-nosed he gets after it
he can catch the ball out of the
backfield and more III just like smaller
quick guys that can get it done and
every now and then don't mess around to
give him 20 carries like they did
yesterday against the Redskins and he
just popped off 4.8 yards per carry
he looks faster than everybody else he
can get around the edge he's smart
enough has great vision and lateral
quickness to be able to work in the
middle of the field as far as
tackles I love his game all right so
everybody's a but I want to do something
I just pulled up
NFL YouTube does this sometimes when a
guy plays well they put out highlight
reel there's a minute 30 reel of Devin
Singletary
so I want to watch it with you and tell
me if any of this reminds me of you I
can stop whatever you want okay so gets
the ball a little pitch out to them
give it another good edge out runs
people to the edge does this feel like
you're watching yourself as Westbrook
watch a screen game love the screen game
look at those as blockers well Luke uses
blockers breaking tackles down the field
running strong I feel like I'm a little
bit faster than him but he runs strong I
think you did have a little bit of a
step up I feel like people are saying
that because you have a similar build
yeah you're both 510 ish ish yeah we're
strong we're muscular we're like we're
sexy obviously you can tell that well I
change you hear that okay all right look
at that run great footwork great vision
you see the patient's right there is
when you see the hole have you ever
watched somebody and gone wow they do
kind of run like me I don't know that
his running style looks like me but his
ability oh that was very you That's not
me it's he makes people miss in the
critical situations he makes people miss
when someone grit running this will
never happen like I'll never have
someone comments me to be like hey I
just saw this broadcaster in Tulsa
Oklahoma
that he reminds me of the next Adam left
oh yeah I guess people can say that [ __ ]
but my thing is is it's interesting when
someone goes this guy reminds me of you
because you might not like the guy you
might not think he's good is this
somebody that you want to be compared to
you well the person that I want to be
compared to me at this point because he
just been going off as Christian
McCaffrey right because he's just so
like if you heard someone like if Terry
Bradshaw on the Fox broadcast was like
you know I've been watching this
Christopher kafir and he reminds me a
lot of Brian's book yeah see see
remember they remember me so Singletary
so yeah I'm like listen young kid this
is Ricky he's young so he's still gonna
continue to get better he's got a small
school like you and listen he's not a
bad back he's not bad he's doing a great
job up there they don't have a big-time
quarterback up there Josh Allen is still
trying to figure this thing out yeah and
so I think he's doing a really good job
and he took advantage of the
reskins team like he should that
yesterday felt like the official passing
of the torch like Frank Gore Frank Gore
went up another rank and in the all-time
rankings its release to play it's crazy
but it felt like they went Devin yet is
his leg injury for a few weeks now it's
his team that's what yesterday felt like
to me
granted it was Washington yes but at the
same point Washington's had a pretty
good run defense this year have they I
think they've been they get tired
because their offense their offense
let's see I did just throw that out
without looking it up ahead of time
they've been okay hold on but feel
pretty good they've been so bad in the
secondary they've been so bad all
offensively that their defense gets run
down all right rushing yards per game
Washington's 28 oh okay so I lied well
you know what it is I still think of
Washington is how they were the the
preseason with how good their deal on
against them they got some big boys and
again they played there spent too much
time gonna field that's the problem with
any line coach Jim Tomsula
that's mom you know Jim he was out he
was in San Francisco I would love to get
[ __ ] up with Jim Tomsula
he's not like to have my team coached by
Jim Tom's I was coached for a week or
two about Jim he was like listen we're
gonna put the pads on it so at the end
of the year oh wait was this the one
week that he coached in order to get the
head coaching job yes here I feel like
it was more than one week but hey maybe
he's on it mate I feel like it was more
than maybe good couple but he was like
listen what we're gonna do we're gonna
wear our practice pants to practice like
usually at the end of the year you
wearing shorts and shells that's it no
we're gonna wear our game you're so
beaten up there you're done we're gonna
actually wear our pants like for what
why are we doing it because we want to
be uniform and stuff like come on coach
we're like birth poor in 12 or whatever
they're 4 and 11 yeah we're we're bad
what are you doing a speaking of teams
that are bad and underperforming this
comes from Luke reeling at elv reeling
this seems like something left ko and
Westbrook have a great tech take on the
next left Coast show I can't wait and it
was about the Baker Mayfield shaved his
facial hair three times during the loss
there is I mean this is the perfect
storm that people kind of want it after
an offseason where the Browns were on
every magazine cover mm-hmm they were
everybody's picked to win the a of
see north they go out there they make
these blockbuster trades the defense has
been building for all these years
Baker is the it quarterback coming up in
the NFL for Odell to be on the sidelines
and people lip-reading for Baker
Mayfield to be so in his own head that
he's shaving multiple times but also
like he looks as though he's regressing
Freddie kitchens who you understand why
the Browns brought him back because when
he was the interim coach the offense
exploded and they almost made it to the
playoffs and now every aspect of it is
going poorly I mean you've been on you
just said you're on a Niners team where
it kind of imploded yes it was bad are
you sensing just complete implosion
right now like is it completely over how
do they get out of this first are they
gonna fire to coach do you have to get
rid of him in his first year though I'm
telling you there you have so many so
much talent on this team you need a
coach that has experience that their
coaches and I'm not saying these guys
disrespect or don't respect coach
kitchens I just think that you need a
coach that has a name brand that people
know that when he walks in the room
everyone's quiet and let's get down to
business that guys are gonna respect
most importantly the quarterback right
then what advantage four kitchens before
you keep going is they do play the
Bengals twice yeah they do play the doll
I got an easier schedule but these next
two weeks versus their three straight
home games home against the bills home
against the Steelers the rejuvenator
well at some point if you talk about
those easier games that we think and as
longer you go further in the schedule
and you keep seeing you continue to lose
games those those easy games of your
city he's harder to win because your
focus as a player gets you get they look
they're really bad against the problem
you listen against the ball just think
about this
the Broncos had 43 plays the Cleveland
Browns had 73 plays 73 they were 1 for 5
in the red zone only scored 19 points
they had an opportunity in that football
game they just couldn't get it done and
right now what you're watching and I and
I kind of feel like Baker just a bit
because they were
were back in the day may my friends he's
always play pool and I always used to
beat him there was just one time
that I couldn't win literally couldn't
win the game and so I'm going upstairs
change my clothes
I got a I'm chasing my hat I'm doing
turning my hat backward putting a rally
cap on doing all types of different
things just to turn the turn the tables
back to what they were they could turn
that's why he's shaving he just had to
figure out how can I write the ship how
can I get things going yeah but that's
what scares me they don't know the pet
he's so in his own head that he's like
it's the facial hair and it's not trying
that like end of the game fourth down he
tried to squeeze it to double coverage
when Odell's got his hand up on the
outside bad decision the thing is with
Baker's I don't feel like he's seen the
field the same way like he's so it's so
like I need to figure this out that he's
not seeing what's in front of him right
now with the with the brows need is a
care coach that has developed
quarterbacks that can develop
quarterbacks that's what they need they
need a running back coach to be their
head yeah they need a guy that can
develop a young quarterback that's what
you have so much talent in the scene but
the quarterback needs to be developed
you need a guy that can do that that has
done it before yeah it's gonna be hard
to find that guy look there's so to
bring this into like relationships and
stuff there are some people that there
are some athletes that we applaud
because they're with their boo from high
school you know what I mean and they've
been there through everything yes and
there's some people we kind of a moan it
when they get to the big leagues and
then they marry somebody you know but
then you have stuff that's like let's
say Dwyane Wade and Gabrielle Union
where you go [ __ ]
feels good that's an alignment of power
and they're gonna make each other so
much better that's right
Baker and and Freddie kitchens the story
was Freddie was the guy that got passed
over for everything and he finally got
this opportunity Baker was the guy that
was a walk-on had to leave all these
schools and he got you know even though
he was the first pick in the draft he
got [ __ ] on the whole draft process he
everyone said he was a bad draft pick
and they've come together and they've
aligned and I think what you're kind of
saying is Baker needs someone that's
gonna make him better
Baker Lisa Sierra yeah Baker needs his
Gabrielle Union he needs someone that's
gonna take him to the next level and
you're saying that right now he's got
his high school boo
and it's nice and it's a good story
story but you need he needs someone
that's gonna push him a little bit more
he's need someone that's gonna say you
know what Baker you don't need to be
talking to the media I need you to go
working your footwork I need you to see
the defense better I need someone that
can read a defense to say I don't need
to throw the ball to the right side you
need to throw the ball to the left side
it just seemed like Freddie's trying to
figure out himself right now
and thus Baker can't go to him and be
like how do I figure my I'm gonna give
you a great analogy and I learned this
when I first got into the horse I bought
a horse farm 12 years ago so almost 13
years ago now yeah thank you and so you
know that means I have no clue I feel
like I should think thank you to that oh
yeah
with Mazal is like my love Congrats yeah
of course I've been around things good
job
this is the truth they say you never
want to have a green rider in a green
horse meaning you don't have a novice
horse and a novice rider as if [ __ ] goes
wrong he might nobody knows what you're
doing that's right and so you want to
get an experienced horse with a novice
rider because they're gonna teach you
tight these are ups and downs
you're gonna go slow you're gonna go
fast if you Rogers had Matloff
absolutely you get in trouble guess
what's gonna happen I'm a slow down and
stop my first horse I would get in
trouble I'm leaning left and right he
would just stop and say you know what
you don't know what the hell you're
doing I'm just gonna stop to protect you
from yourself you need that at this
point you made a great comparison Aaron
Rodgers the floor the floor Aaron
Rodgers has been there has done that
Matt Lafleur young Hitler's caught up
Rodgers can look to the cylon hi Gary
I'll run hurry up I've done this for the
let me do it my thing you need yourself
a veteran head coach with this team and
the English you got a lot of
personalities on this team - neither
veteran head coach has been there that
has developed talent I think Bruce
Arians would have been perfect he wanted
to go there would have been perfect
there and I'm sure Bruce Arians is
looking at Jameis and go and I wish I
[ __ ] was there I wonder can I out
coach the Seahawks the entire game be up
double digits most of the game and I
still got Jameis Winston with his baby
hands
squirt in the ball back hey miss whisset
he likes them he's like she had likes to
fumble holy crap he was going here in
the bog it just kind of went up and also
like I have two things I need you off my
chest one
Jameis get [ __ ] LASIK surgery stop
squinting or buy some glasses or wear
contacts
we're goggles weird - Eric Dickerson
goggle yeah
rankings something you clearly have an
inability of seeing distances because
the only time I squint is when I don't
have my contacts in second thing is this
is my yearly speech
just because Odell is on the sidelines
and is upset does not mean he's a diva
I watched Tom Brady on the bench on
Sunday night for ten minutes
cursing at himself grabbing his hair and
freaking out and I went oh he's a
competitor but when Odell's on the
sidelines upset because he he's not
upset he didn't get the ball he's upset
because they're not winning the brush
the situation Dell if Jarvis would have
caught the fourth down pass and they
drove down in Odell didn't touch the
ball and Nick Chubb scored a touchdown
he'd be over there celebrating it's just
this need to go Odell is upset
Divac has returned back off well to your
point and I think so unless you're
making a great point and they do that
they the media picks and chooses they
pick and choose a guy Tom Brady hit but
someone it's a hold is oh he's just
passionate about it and you're right
about it someone else does it Odell
Beckham jr. he's a bad guy
Odell Beckham jr. had her at a press
conference last week and I thought it
showed the maturity he said I'm gonna
I'm gonna stand here and I have my
quarterbacks back I've been there I'm
gonna I'm gonna help them it to me that
showed a lot of maturity especially in
the face of the terrible season that
they're having that sort of a bunch of
maturity I think we're seeing growth I
also see it think we're seeing a lot of
frustration for him he that there are
everyone including huh everyone in
Cleveland is frustrated I mean China
president was so frustrated that he
threatened yeah fanon just got really
loose that white head but you know what
I have a third speech doesn't work give
me more to all of you fans out there
that want to use social media to [ __ ] on
your team I get it man there were years
the Eagles sucked and I'd let him have
it he and sometimes there be players
that I thought were not playing great
okay here's the first thing I'm gonna
say stop adding them
if you want the player to yell at you if
you want the player to go off the rails
if you want your player to go into the
locker room and say screw this franchise
and their team and their fans Adam but
why would you want that guys these
players are searching for themselves
already trust me they type their name
into the search bar and they'll find it
but what you don't need as a fan is for
the player to go on their phone and go
oh Jimmy just said I'm a piece of [ __ ]
loser that should die let's just stop no
you know I don't agree with you there oh
my god and I'll tell you why how they're
not playing anymore oh yeah partly that
yes but I don't think that the fans
should get personal with it they can say
you know what Brian Westbrook missed a
whole 30 times and he fumbled you say
don't like that at 36 that's per no no
but if they say at you know what this is
what you did wrong bah blah blah blah
you can't say you're an [ __ ] you're a
jerk and you're mother of the stink you
can't say that the same way that I don't
have a problem with of course I don't
have a problem with and I think a lot of
fans do it you know what Brian Westrick
had a great game he did all these things
at 36 West Virginia so it goes both ways
I mean if I'm a fan I should be able to
express my displeasure as long as it's
not personal I think there's no matter
what if let's say Eagles fans have had
an issue let's say with Odell
okay if you're a Browns fan yeah you
walk into a restaurant and there's Odell
huh you're not gonna walk up to him and
go you [ __ ] sob salute your a diva
but you're probably gonna go up to him
be like how you doing man can I get an
autograph yeah or or let's say you don't
know an augur person you're gonna go
what's going on right now of course you
know I just I don't understand why we
interact directly with people on social
media I know why we do it because it's
we're anonymous and we could do whatever
we want it makes little range though but
that's what if you're a fan that kind of
that's you want that though if you're a
fan if I'm a fan I would want that and
again I want to curse to people
no no no again it's not gonna be
personal it's gonna be objective about
the game for me if I'm a fan this is
what what sucks about this player
remember he did all these things and he
fumbled at the end Kirk Cousins you know
what Kirk Cousins
you had a chance to win a football game
you had the
all in your hands and you guys went
three and out they lost seven yards at
Kirk Cousins I'm not gonna if you win
I'm gonna say you know we're at Kirk
Cousins guess what you're the best
quarterback the Vikings could have had
I'm glad that they paid your debt money
you deserve it but when it gets personal
that's the problem that I have my fourth
rent is people that have their own shows
should not rant about how other people
should use their social media I
apologize there you go do whatever the
[ __ ] you want you [ __ ] let me get a
few more of these tweets because we're
getting closer to an hour and a half
Dylan Behrens at bloops at bloop 33
which is funny because here at bleacher
report there's a slack channel called
bloops one current people post pictures
of their their cute animals yeah I got
three dogs oops excuse me it's the loose
soups and Engler found this funny
because I went in there and I posted a
picture of an ant farm and I said here
are my children and I posted like 500
names yeah that's cool yeah no it's not
cool don't know any pets I've got three
dogs and I own a horse for my got eight
horses okay what are your dog's names
Nico is a Belgian Malinois I might ask
for the breeds I'm just trying to give
you a little context I don't want it you
know you don't even care about the names
you suck as a probably do alright Nico
sorry
laughter Nico Thorpe okay goes a small
Spanish bred dachshund yeah do that and
what are your other two have got E
what does Goti got he's a faithful dog a
fret that good name in Harley Quinn
Harley Quinn is a Maltese she's a French
Bulldog okay
multi I had a Maltese grown up [ __ ] you
did you yeah why did you lose a bet or
something that your parents wanted to
punish you that dog died you sorry sorry
sorry sorry for your loss okay like dogs
died how did he die
I mean it was a she and she got old just
like so what do you why did you tell me
that he'd that of course he'd she died
of course yeah her name was I can't do
in the sweater pool see because it's hot
as your tuggers anyone want to get a fan
in here something would be nice blue 33
said you have to be hot in this sweater
yeah that looks hot oh I get
so what happens right here yeah thanks
Adam laughs code doesn't know anything
about the Texans and it makes me sad
listening to the pod to get to the
Texans defense isn't good Watson is
amazing and that's all I have to say
about the Texans I have already
apologized you know what though I did
kind of say exactly what I said that
deshaun Watson carries his team um I
think the defense is okay he does so
that's fair I will say this I've been
very pleasantly surprised by Carlos Hyde
I think Carlos Hyde's been a lot better
than what people like he was a running
punch line about how he's got a lot of
great teams yeah um he would hold up to
the ball and go into the ends I wanna be
nice too but he's been running his butt
off DeAndre Hopkins is a monster yeah
Kenny Stills has been a wonderful
addition to this team when they get will
fuller back it's even gonna get better I
would have to imagine that the offensive
line will improve and once those rookies
get back from injury whether it's the
end of this year or next year that will
be a unit on the rise they do have a
defensive line though that is going to
need kind of a refurbishing I don't
think JJ's got that many years left
Davie and clowny is gone
witty merciless is getting up there in
age I love DJ reader yeah I think DJ
reader is one of the lesser known
defensive linemen that creates pressure
in this league I'm not the biggest fan
of their corners I'm not the biggest fan
of their safeties and then they're a
very good team that has an all-world
quarterback and so I apologize mr. bloop
at the same time I like DJ reader and I
like your wide receivers I like your
running back so they're defense
obviously is great because JJ Watt
played play well I shouldn't say great
they were okay roars to three points
yeah that's that's not saying much
I know Nick Foles gonna be back soon
they got out their mints you just a
little bit too they they were after him
came back to earth yeah Brandon poke
grass at be poke wrasse poke your ass
can the Jets get any worse and does darn
'old have a shot if case isn't fired
Jets lose to the Dolphins two touchdowns
for Preston well there's no way they'd
fire Adam GaSe no way through the fire
more likely to get fired Adam GaSe or
Freddie kitchens already told from their
first year pretty kids you think so I
would not fire at him get him case was
bad when he was in Miami
did not hire Adam GaSe Adam GaSe was
hired and Joe Douglas came in the same
Joe Douglas that looked at the roster
and said these are my guys I think that
they believe the Jets believe that Adam
GaSe can bring the quarterback along I
don't think that they feel the same way
about Freddie kitchens in that football
team what is there but the talk that I
see on Jets Twitter right now is sand
Arnold's regressing this team's not by
you directive yeah he had mono for a
month - so I mean yeah that kind of
slows people down just a bit but do you
have any faith in Adam GaSe no I do not
I I do not at all and they got they have
some weapons and
it was funny to me that everyone wanted
Robby Anderson at the trade deadline cuz
I'm like well he had 21 catches at that
point now that's it
yeah he just to speed you guys though
it's like their offensive line is so bad
yeah that's that's my hardest thing is
evaluating coaches and quarterbacks when
I would argue the offensive line
determines the success of your team of
course if you win in the trenches you
got a chance to win it's also been
amazing that levy our bill hasn't
complained it off in a levy on and
O'Dell two dudes that were seen as divas
no problem quiet and professional they
got also got paid - so right it's a lot
easier to shut your mouth when you guys
just go home - got millions in Leh oh
man that feels good I'll come back next
year I'm sorry we'll be all right I
think I think that well you also got to
think about you think Freddy kitchens
gets fired and gates doesn't I think so
I think that because here's the thing
with the Jets it there was a part maybe
three four weeks ago I'm like you know
what they may not be too bad this year
they beat the Cowboys right before might
have been right before he went he got
sick with mono me well no no they beat
the Cowboys and like his first game back
and everybody let's work on the jet
that's right yeah yeah and then they
they got shut out on Monday at football
training the way people in the trade
deadline you're talking about getting
rid of guys and that that doesn't sit
well in the locker room it just does and
obviously Jamal Adams was pissed off
about it next Sunday jets-giants Battle
of New York Giants playing the the
Cowboys on Monday Night Football so
we'll see I kind of feel like the Giants
are better but I don't know that to be
true yeah it's a bad matchup that not a
bad match so it's just too bad football
teams all right Jackson lass goes at
Jackson lass goes
guys any new confidence in the Eagles
next two games as Bella check and the
Patriots just lost and the Seattle
struggled against Tampa Bay so after the
by the Eagles faced the Patriots and
Seahawks both at home do you have any
more confidence
seeing as how those two teams struggled
in week 9 if your Eagle Spann you you
just wish last night went differently
for the Patriots you wish it they would
have won been nine and oh then going to
the PI kind of relax what you don't want
is a pissed-off Bill Belichick with the
week extra week you have actually week
two but I know I hate that matchup
coming in to the link with the way that
I saw that team react on this island
they were upset what happened last week
and they're gonna get out there I'm glad
the Eagles lost their lead against the
Bears because now they go into the bye
week not feeling themselves I don't know
I don't know if they would have let's
say it ended up being 20 to 14 let's say
the Bears don't score or the Eagles
score low and they win like 30 to 6
right right they would have gone in kind
of high and mighty and there's something
about kind of letting a lead evaporate
and having to go on an eight-minute
drive to seal the game yeah making a few
big throws to urge got it across the
middle and some place to the young kid
what's his name Mike Sanders Sanders
that that there's something about that
reality check Alshon Jeffery played a
bad game got a kiss the ball house I
know that but I do what do you think is
it better to go into the bye week
feeling high and mighty knowing the
Patriots are coming up next or is it
better going in kind of getting a little
taste here on medicine well I don't know
that that gave him a taste of their own
medicine I really don't feel that way I
saw the guys celebrating after the game
I think they were just happy that they
want at this point the rapport they just
happy today warm who said so everyone
that they lost to the Cowboys 37 to 10
yeah they lost by 27 who said that next
day that they were gonna come back and
beat the bills and the Bears oh no
someone on the team huh I have no clue
it was about you yeah pretty good well I
think I think the bills and the Bears
are the same team for the most part good
defense
yes shitty quarterback bad I mean know
who was a guy at that texture they told
me that true Biscay was gonna be oh
you're getting you're too hard on your
Biscay when did i text you that so
someone text you that and saw that I'm
like how about timeout this is no good
Chiba ski looked bad I mean missing wide
open receivers yesterday
wide open receivers yesterday and the
thing is is like okay so try Biscay you
know everyone talks about he was with
the Watson in mahomes drafts but the
thing about your Biscay was he could
always run and I we weren't even getting
that anymore
no he I'm trying to think of what he did
good he ran the ball a little bit he has
a strong arm I think he struggles with
his accuracy
he threw a great deep ball yesterday
more than one shot get one shot to tell
if everyone rate great deep boy if he'd
let him was a touchdown but I feel
confident about the Eagles from this
point I again thought they were gonna go
into the buy at either four and five or
maybe three and six and for them to beat
the bills and the Bears and to go in the
buy at five and four I look at the fact
that they play still Miami and
Washington and two matchups with the
Giants and I go Miami's hot right now
though [ __ ] that bro if you're not
winning Miami that I don't talk about
the playoffs but like you're beating
Miami and Washington yeah and you should
be able to beat the Giants twice with
this current constitution of the Giants
that's nine wins and now with the
Patriots Seahawks and Cowboys you steal
one of those let's say you beat the
Cowboys let's say you listen to the no
you can't attend if you can't attend and
you split with the Cowboys you can make
the playoffs yeah you went in division
you get to ten and so that's what I'm
saying is with Miami Washington and two
Giants games the rest of the schedule
has been set up that's that's that's
what I get to eight with those that's
nine Oh Miami Washington and they play
they're trying twice okay that's nine so
I'm saying so they have to beat Seattle
Lou hey treants or doe Dallas I think
we're counting our wins it's scary I
think that the Patriots is a loss I
think they could beat Seattle though at
home at home and I think it's just I
think the Cowboys had the number I think
they have the ability to run and throw
the ball deep which you can almost say
the same thing for a Seattle we're gonna
see Cowboys to me are O'Doyle they
kicked the [ __ ] out of like defenseless
kids at recess yeah but one day I don't
know O'Doyle I have a feeling your whole
family's going down really you feel
Billy Madison
yeah banana-peel car goes off
clever dueling rules Oh rules you didn't
like that movie I'm not a big was that
an Adam Sandler
yeah I'm not I'm not a fan can you name
three Adam Sandler movies listed a
little uh little hockey what's the movie
that he's he's playing golf
what's the golf movie that he there's a
hockey something happen happy gilmore I
hated it I hated Billy matter they're
all the same then there's another movie
we had a little care Reese's Cups and
happy gilmore yes Madison yeah no good
there was the one that he's like their
mentor to the little kid Big Daddy
yeah hated their to hate it all III hate
although you know that a lot of people
say that I remind them of Adam Sandler
is that why you kind of secretly [ __ ]
hate me I'm a my truth I needed to speak
my truth sometimes
by the way Fletcher Cox texted me and he
said you're Reese's cup takes sucks but
your consummation [ __ ] he isn't playing
good recently yes be playing ball he's
involved it out I use like hey Jake
doesn't know what he's talking over here
and you have a Reese's puffs box which
is pissing me off every time I look at
the dog G put up there
bad person that gives okay was really
nice to talk to pat pat today yes thanks
Batman I think it's good to have I think
this show needed you know the super
Patriots fan to really let us know how
he felt the patient should be concerned
because I think they got exposed and you
know remember back in the day was always
like you know when you play the Patriots
in there everybody you play after that
they'll expose you
maybe that's the Ravens now maybe to
everyone that plays the Patriots it has
a blueprint on them a little bit now hmm
I want to do a social experiment if you
guys got to this point the podcast god
bless you it's really deep in there this
is my social experiment I am going to
say something coming up that I do not
believe to be true okay but I think that
the internet is very manipulative all
and manipulatable and I'd like to take
advantage of it there's still so here's
what I want to do I'm about to say
something I do not believe and what I
want you guys to do if you get to this
point of the podcast is to clip out only
the part of me saying it so that what
we're gonna do is you're not the warning
not the warning and then you're gonna
post it and you're gonna go I can't
believe that left go thinks the Patriots
are dying yeah but then what I get to do
is I get to say oh that was completely
taken out of context you loved it so I
just want to try this love the out of
context comment yeah they're great so I
let me just say this I didn't
that the Patriots dynasty is ending and
I think that anyone says that is an
idiot but let's see the internet take
hold of this so just a social experiment
look at the camera
I firmly believe that the Patriots are
coming to an end
Belichick just doesn't seem to have it
anymore it's over Brady has an arm that
isn't warranting of top 20 in the NFL
and I think we finally have seen the end
of the Patriots reign and it is a new
league
it is the Texans it is the ravens it is
the Chiefs new day and I think I'm
finally ready to say it the Patriots are
dead dead
no again I don't believe anything that
I've just said but if someone wanted to
clip that out I don't believe any of it
and then put that on the Internet no I'm
happy to refute that I just wanted to
try the people don't internet love
calling you a jerk and stupid it's great
and unsmoked
I sit back yeah I put my feet up that's
right smoke a little daddy cigar Lord
daddy cigar look at my fiance uh-huh
beautiful fiancee you have Thanks I was
able to see you guys on Saturday I
appreciate he's under for he thought was
a figment of you thought man I never had
seen her so I'm you kept more talking my
anal and enum and this and then the
other end she's dope she's tall too
which I don't like why cuz we're having
some tall ass no cuz she's gonna be
she's taller than me she was kind of
towering over me not in like that I went
see I wanted to go in for the hug just
because you weren't good friend and I
wanted to give her a hug but I gave her
a handshake because hi I don't like
towering over me I don't like that and
she may have like brought you in like
she kind of it would women do because
there's so night I could tell this she's
sweet she would she would have dipped
down low which makes me even more it
just makes me even more infuriated she's
gonna love it
she would have dipped down low and
embraced me yeah like I'm a little kid
and I don't like that okay it was a
perfect time to end I don't like that
alright I'll tell her that you said that
oh she's so sweet and so I just had no
bending yeah yeah
511 ish for Westbrook the Rocket Man
I am the lef koe man and we will holla
holla holla atcha lena pol everybody